a member of the science and humanities
scholars program today Sophie Rose zuker
is earning a bachelor's degree in
chemistry with university honors and a
bachelor's degree in creative writing
with college honors sophie has been an
active member of the Carnegie Mellon
community serving on the Executive Board
of Alpha Chi Omega sorority president of
morph CMU's feminist club and
editor-in-chief of the Oakland review
CMU's literary magazine following
graduation Sophie will work for epic
systems of Madison Wisconsin a software
company for healthcare organizations
Sophie thank you for that wonderful
introduction dr. Suresh um thank you
everyone how do I look all right let's
begin my heart is in the work oh those
words have followed us throughout our
college careers haven't they they were
pressed into our minds during
orientation spoken with passion and
rigor by university officials
upperclassmen and staff as they promised
us that we too would part our hearts in
the work we would be Andrew Carnegie
when I was a high school junior those
words inspired me my favorite subject in
school was Latin and I thought I would
never drink in college oh sorry it's
raining guys I walked through Carnegie
Mellon's campus and I saw myself here in
a world of people passionate about their
studies and passionate about the future
when i was a freshman my heart is in the
work challenged me i think it challenged
all of us right challenged us to sign up
for the most student organizations at
the
he's fair I don't know about you but I
think I'm still on the Tartans d-list
challenge just to take on classes we
knew we probably shouldn't be taking his
freshman despite our advisors
recommendations and challenged us to
step out of our comfort zones sometimes
my heart is in the work translated to
work hard play hard and each of us
interpreted that in our own way maybe it
was going to my first college party and
seeing a guy breathe fire in front of me
maybe it was my friend who called me at
six thirty in the morning I was it from
a walk home down more wood just to tell
someone her secrets or maybe it was my
roommate who started research with
faculty her freshman year and saw the
path to her future laid out in front of
her bright and clear as we progressed
through college though my heart is in
the work took on a nasty meaning it
became a curse a pejorative a joke it
became something we muttered at 3am
while struggling throughout problem sets
or during long weekends in practice
rooms and acting studios where our
hearts really in the work as we planned
another event we knew nobody would
attend and where our hearts in the work
at midnight on sundays and hunt library
trying to finish lab reports gorging on
snack food and redbull in the middle of
my sophomore year i sat in my advisors
office asking him for guidance about
what to do that summer I didn't know
where to go I felt like I should start
doing research because everyone in the
chemistry department does research and
sophomore summer was too late to start
research and I wanted to take more
writing classes I wouldn't have time for
research during the year I just couldn't
do it all I grew frantic panicked and I
was about to cry when he just calmly
looked at me and he said Sophie over the
past year and has seemed that chemistry
has excited you less and less and other
things have excited you more and just
like that a whole world opened up for me
the thing was I loved putting my heart
into work I think we all did right I
loved hearing my friends tell me about
their research and I love the moment I
understood what they were saying I got
the science yay science but it meant
something special to them and it didn't
mean anything special to me I had spent
time and energy and heart on a field I
thought I could settle into and settle
for but when it came down to it I
realized it was stupid to settle when
other people weren't I realized the
things that have brought me the most
satisfaction during my time here were
outside the classroom of my primary
major and I don't think I'm alone it's
not that my heart wasn't in the work it
was just in other work it was in other
classes in another academic department
that wasn't on the path I imagined for
myself but that made me feel like I was
doing something new something meaningful
but two majors weren't enough is enough
ever enough for CMU kids I threw myself
into planning recruitment with my
sorority Alpha Chi Omega and I spent
hours with the feminist club watching
with glee as I saw an entire lecture
hall filled with students taking time to
hear about women's bodies it was more
than just other work I found love in
late night meetings with executive
boards performing weird skits with the
chemistry department and building a
booth extracurriculars became another
academic program another degree another
world outside problem sets a world of
group me texts doodle polls and google
calendar who among us doesn't know this
world whether we were our a's TAS
research team members team captains or
chapter presidents no one is leaving
this campus with that having been a part
of something outside the work we set out
to do why did these activities seem
matter just as much if not more than
another assignment to turn in by the
midnight deadline somewhere along the
line the people around us became friends
we connected with on a different level
than just getting things done you've
probably heard that were among the
smartest best educated most privileged
people in the world well duh despite the
trials and difficulties each of us have
faced both inside and outside of this
tiny tiny campus we are all incredibly
lucky to be above all else super smart
come on pat yourself on the back smart
asses you know what that means don't you
we can't waste our brains we have an
obligation to do things that matter
Carnegie Mellon has not been an amazing
experience just because of our classes
as we head out to careers to graduate
programs to our parents couches we must
realize that sometimes what made us
happiest at CMU wasn't the work itself
it was the heart to put into things and
the care it was the TAS who guided us
through concepts of mathematics and the
friends who helped to solve problems
that would never end the advisers and
professors who guided us towards paths
with meaning and purpose and the times
we became mentors leaders and guides my
heart is in the work doesn't tell us to
mindlessly dedicate our hearts to
working for the sake of work it's a
promise to bring heart into work to do
the things we do with heart with passion
and with care now I'm not saying each of
us should dedicate our lives to solving
the world's biggest problems although
like at least one of us should deal with
the sustainable energy crisis chemical
engineers
maybe material science one of you can
when you take care of that thank you but
honestly most of us are going to spend
the next five maybe ten years doing
stuff that isn't our dream job and
that's okay it's normal the things I
found myself able to put the most
passion into during my time here we're
outside the classroom maybe work will be
like that too maybe some of us will
struggle to find meaning in the 925 in
tax forms and our long commutes but what
I ask of all of us and what I hope for
myself is that we put our hearts into a
work we know how to work hard we've
spent how many years practicing it our
more challenging work will be to work
with our hearts to bring not only skill
talent and intelligence but kindness
thoughts and love into what we do every
day into our workplaces communities and
families to treat the people outside the
Carnegie Mellon bubble with the same
respect and wide-eyed wonder as we
treated each other to view the world as
optimistically as we did here while
Andrew Carnegie is was a great
businessman he's not remembered for his
businesses he's remembered for his
philanthropy Carnegie Hall carnegie
museums the carnegie libraries carnegie
mellon university andrew carnegie spent
his entire life putting his heart into
work but his great sorrow was to wait
until the end of his career to put heart
into the arts education service the good
of the common man the things he cared
about why shouldn't we in the spirit of
innovation improve upon his legacy
as we leave class of 2016 let's make my
heart is in the work a promise to bring
our hearts into our work thank you